[Music]
cloud spanner is unique in the
marketplace because it combines both
relational database structure with
horizontal scale and performance what
this means is that this significantly
simplifies application development and
database management allowing you to
deliver your apps faster for example for
globally distributed apps cloud spanners
multi-regional configuration
automatically replicates a database
across continents allowing for localized
reads minimizing latency creating or
scaling such a globally replicated
database only takes a handful of clicks
on the console at Google we use cloud
spanner for our own mission-critical
services and apps that billions of
people across the world access every day
so downtime just isn't an option this
hands-on lab shows you how to create a
cloud spanner instance database and
table add a schema write and modify data
and run a query cloud spanner is ideal
for relational structured and
semi-structured data that requires high
availability strong consistency and
transactional reads and writes next up
on our quest is the Internet of Things
QuickStart
[Music]